does that make sense now pause for a
second put down your pen and think with
me I have the Exxon detail the question
gave it to me I want D s on detail we've
seen this many times before I need to
somehow connect these two derivatives
together how am I going to do it what
derivatives could I string together that
would give me D S on DT okay we'll start
with this one because I actually know
what that is DX on DT that's known what
does I multiply it by D S on D X and our
X's will cancel okay now this is a
really good sign because it now charts
the path forward right DX on DT that's
given D S on D X I need a relationship
between X and s that will help me work
out what is going on like I can then
differentiate that and then I can put it
in place okay
so having a look at the relationship
between s and X it might have helped you
if you drew a simpler diagram which sort
of teased out all of it like get LeBron
out there get the lamp out of the way
it's just a pair of triangles right do
you see the triangles here they are this
is what's really going on okay this is
two this is six you had a couple of via
angles here because you assumed the
other bond has good posture thumbs up
okay now I want to relationship between
this value and this value and you might
have caught the spoilers from before
what piece of geometry is going to help
me with that it's gonna be similar
triangles right now this question is not
about similar triangles so I'm not going
to labor the proof I'd have to label
everything it's not talking about things
if I had lots of time I would prove it
but can you see what one relationship
something over something equals
something else over something else
what's going to capture the geometry
here and put s and X in the same
equation okay so I could say I could say
6 over 2 6 over 2 that's a big side
compared to a little side a big triangle
little triangle so what's the
corresponding leg in this same big
triangle
it's the whole length right X plus s is
on the top what's on the bottom whatever
you happen to a corner I've caught a s
foreshadow because at least I can
remember that way okay there's a bit of
simplification that can happen so that's
nice what am I going to get here bless
you three s equals x plus s do you see
how quickly the relationship fell out
which step was this have a think back I
gave you three this morning remember in
our overall strategy this is step two
we've got all of the variables and
constants we know what to do with them
but this is the equation the measurement
the geometry that helped us connect all
the dots rim let's just tidy this up I
want D s on D X so I guess I should have
s in terms of X yeah so I've got 2 s
that equals that you happy with that so
what's this going to be that derivative
D S on DX
it's just 1/2 that's nice and easy right
so I can just say tada d s on DX
people's oh you care with that so what
can we do here can someone would someone
be so bold as to try and help me work
out it looks like we've actually
answered B before we are today and
that's fine if I just say be here right
D s on D T that was what I was trying to
solve
what's it equal to okay um hold on where
are we
DX on your teeth first because that's
what I had from the question which is
just 1 I think it's important to write
one even though it doesn't change the
odds are it shows I understand where
this is coming from multiplied by 1/2 so
I can interpret that that means that the
shadow is growing up half a meter per
second are you happy with that
okay can we rewind now can we answer a
does anyone you don't have to call it
out but I wanted does anyone have it on
it's a fait yeah
yeah no okay so we can do this a bunch
of different ways we can think about
this intuitively if you like how much is
this growing by this shadow every second
how much is it growing by half a meter
right but in addition to it growing by
half a meter every second it's also
moving right it doesn't stay still
where is it going what directory is it
going in it's going in the same
direction
that it's growing does that make sense
so a moves that one meter per second
that way and it also gets bigger at a
half a meter per second right so what's
the total that you expect in terms of
that tip moving one and a half meters
altogether right so that's a way you can
intuitively think about that how do I
write that down
well what's the derivative here's the
derivative he was searching for for a
what is the derivative sorry for B
what's the do video I'm searching for
for a what is this whole leg it's all
make here it's well the way I've drawn
it over there
it's the it's the change in X plus s
right there's a where LeBron is and
that's where shadow is and I'm comparing
that with time do you agree with that
it's a bit we wouldn't usually see this
written like this because you know
there's weird things up there but it's
just a number just like that's a number
and that's a number and that's a number
okay now we actually know what s is in
terms of X don't we have a look there it
is it's X on to right so can I write it
like this
it's just substitution are you happy
with that thumbs up and I know how to
combine those two that's three on two
times X how's your brain so far have I
done everything is okay
at the moment now you know when you
write don't have to write this down
you know when you're right dy/dx you're
used to thinking of that as just like a
fraction rise over run okay
but you can just as easily write that
rather than just as a fraction you can
write it as an operator right you
remember when we first introduced the
differential operator as an operator
applied to a function yeah like this
mean the same thing you can see if it
wanted to then Y could just hop up the
top like that okay I can do the same
thing here it's written as a fraction
right now but I'm going to rewrite it as
an operator applied to what function
three-on-two times X but you know one of
the handy things about on
differentiating right is when you've got
constant coefficients what difference do
they make to the derivative what
difference they make like do you have to
use product rule on this because 3 on 2
times X you don't do the the constant
coefficient just hey at the front if you
wanted 3 on 2 right it's just a constant
coefficient times what's left behind DX
on DT but you know what that is don't
you write DX on DT is just 1 and there's
that one and a half meters per second
that you told me to begin with through
your intuition okay
there's lots of ways to illustrate that
one that's just a particular way but I
like that it pushes you to think about
what all this differentiation means so
how's your head doing all these
questions early on they're like wow I've
never seen anything like this who
thought to use similar triangles well
some of you did some of you didn't want
so obvious but now that you've seen them
you're going to be a lot more able to
recognize them in the future
does anyone have any questions